A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. Or on our website.
清凉的泉水将触及你心灵的深处。那些蔚蓝而雄伟的巨浪可以推动你向前，也能带来平静与慰藉。从密歇根的这片海岸到那片海岸。只需用心感受当下流淌的瞬间。让浩瀚的湖泊、河流和小溪勾勒出永恒的记忆。纵身跃入纯净的密歇根，让清新的水流洗涤你的心灵。访问 Michigan.org 或我们的网站，了解更多新鲜资讯。
The Hume Freeway is one of the busiest interstate routes in Australia, linking the country's two most populous cities, Sydney and Melbourne. Stretching for 840 kilometres, the Hume is part of the Ozilink National Network, providing a vital connection for freight and transit between the two major East Coast cities. In 2013, the creation of the whole Brook Bypass marked the completion of an extensive overhaul of the roadway, with Sydney and Melbourne now linked by a continuous dual-lane freeway, unrestricted by the traffic lights and speed restrictions of passing townships. But it wasn't always this way.
休姆高速公路是澳大利亚最繁忙的城际公路之一，连接着该国人口最多的两个城市——悉尼和墨尔本。休姆高速公路全长 840 公里，是澳捷联国家网络的一部分，为两大东海岸城市之间的货运和交通提供了至关重要的连接。2013 年，整个布鲁克绕城公路的建成标志着这条公路大规模改造工程的完工，悉尼和墨尔本如今由一条连续的双车道高速公路相连，不再受过往城镇红绿灯和速度限制的约束。但情况并非一直如此。
Prior to the upgrade, the Hume Freeway was the Hume Highway. Those navigating the old Hume had to drive through a vast number of urban and rural townships, traffic lights and intersections. Despite the bypass upgrades that occurred throughout the years, one aspect of the Hume has remained the same. It is the only road providing access to the Balingalos State Forest. Located 130 kilometres southwest of Sydney in the southern highlands region of New South Wales, Balingalos State Forest stretches for 40 square kilometres and comprises 700 hectares of commercial pine plantations, bordered by several thousand hectares of native bushland. Entrance is gained only by driving or walking through the seemingly endless rows of dense pine trees.
在升级之前，休姆高速公路曾是休姆公路。那些行驶在老休姆公路上的人必须穿过大量城市和乡村城镇、红绿灯以及十字路口。尽管多年来进行了绕城公路升级，但休姆公路有一个方面保持不变。它是通往巴林加洛斯国家森林的唯一道路。巴林加洛斯国家森林位于新南威尔士州南部高地地区，在悉尼西南 130 公里处，绵延 40 平方公里，包含 700 公顷的商业松树人工林，四周环绕着数千公顷的原生灌木林。进入该森林的唯一途径是驾车或步行穿过看似无尽的茂密松树林。
The forest is home to a plethora of native flora and fauna, including koalas, wombats, kangaroos and many species of birds. Providing a popular recreation spot for campers, trail bike riders, bushwalkers, picnickers and photographers, many parts of the seemingly endless rugged terrain are so remote that can only be accessed by a four-wheel drive or on foot. Entrance to Balingalos is gained via the Hume, 16 kilometres south of the southern highlands town of Bowerill, where a sealed road quickly gives way to rocky dirt roads, steep hills and creek crossings impossible to navigate without an off-road vehicle. Fire trails and a complex network of tracks and paths crisscross throughout the forest, which is so large and isolated that it's rare to encounter another person whilst visiting. There are no signs or obvious landmarks to signify one's location within, making it a very easy place to get disoriented and lost.
这片森林是众多本土动植物的家园，包括考拉、袋熊、袋鼠和许多鸟类。这里是露营者、越野自行车手、丛林徒步者、野餐者和摄影师的热门休闲胜地，看似无尽的崎岖地形中有许多地方非常偏远，只能驾驶四驱车或步行才能到达。进入巴林加洛斯需要经由休姆公路，在南部高地城镇鲍威利以南 16 公里处，铺砌的公路很快就会变成岩石泥路、陡峭的山丘和不驾驶越野车根本无法通过的溪流。森林中纵横交错着防火道以及复杂的轨道和路径，这里如此之大且与世隔绝，以至于在游览时很难遇到其他人。里面没有任何标志或明显的路标来标明自己所在的位置，这使得这里成为一个非常容易迷失方向和迷路的地方。
The forest is thought to have been named by an early 1800s settler who was so enchanted by the untamed beauty of the area that he christened at Balingalo, meaning Good Angel. Despite its splendour and distinctively Australian landscape which continues to attract nature lovers and outdoor enthusiasts from all over the world, those who venture to the secluded forest note the vast space is enveloped by neary silence. As visitors turn to the forest entrance, a large ominous sign surrounded by a wall of towering trees warns. Welcome to Balingalo State Forest. Please be careful. In the 1990s, over 200,000 young travellers ventured to Australia each year. Attracted by the sun, surf and rugged natural beauty of the country's varied landscape, travellers were promised exotic and exciting adventures. The backpacking lifestyle offered young people the opportunity to develop their independence, gain new experiences and interact with a wide range of new people from all over.
人们认为这片森林是以 19 世纪初的一位定居者的名字命名的，他被该地区未受破坏的美景深深迷住，于是将其命名为巴林加洛，意为“好天使”。尽管它拥有壮丽的景色和独特的澳大利亚景观，不断吸引着来自世界各地的自然爱好者和户外运动爱好者，但那些冒险进入这片人迹罕至的森林的人注意到，这片广阔的空间被近乎绝对的寂静所笼罩。当游客转向森林入口时，一堵高耸的树墙包围着一个巨大而不祥的标志，上面警告着：“欢迎来到巴林加洛斯国家森林。请小心。”20 世纪 90 年代，每年有超过 20 万年轻游客前往澳大利亚。由于被该国多变景观的阳光、冲浪和崎岖的自然美景所吸引，游客们被承诺会有异国情调和令人兴奋的冒险。背包客的生活方式为年轻人提供了培养独立性、获得新体验以及与来自各地的形形色色的人互动的机会。
Most backpackers who arrived to Australia were aged in their early to mid-20s and either taking time off between studying or securing their first professional jobs or wanting to figure out their next step in life. A majority travelled alone or with one other person, stayed in the country for an average visit of six months and either lived frugally off their hard-earned savings or funded their trip as they went with fruit-picking jobs, bar shifts, nannying or casual farm work. 40% of backpackers came from the UK and another 30% ventured over from continental Europe. Backpacking accounted for a major part of the country's tourism industry, contributing approximately $1.5 billion to the Australian economy annually. In the days before the internet, backpackers relied on word of mouth to plan their trips. Knowledge was passed from one traveller to the next, the best destinations to visit, the areas to avoid and the cheapest ways to get from place to place. Noticeboards on display at hostels provided an invaluable resource to tourists seeking travel companions or looking to share the cost of transit with many backpackers partnering up to cut costs and make new friends. Trains and buses were a common form of transport but many budget travellers also purchased cheaper used cars so they could cover more ground at their own pace. Although it was often frowned upon, hitchhiking provided another popular method of transit. Hitching provided a cheap, convenient way to move around for those on tight budgets while allowing visitors to meet locals and learn all about the area they were traversing by the people who lived there. Although this risky practice was strongly discouraged by police and many employers advised truck drivers against picking up hitchhikers, in the 90s it was a common way for travellers to get around.
大多数抵达澳大利亚的背包客年龄在 20 岁出头到 25 岁左右，他们要么是在学业结束后或找到第一份正式工作前休假，要么是想弄清楚人生的下一步。大多数人独自旅行或与另外一人同行，平均在澳大利亚停留六个月，要么靠辛苦赚来的积蓄过着简朴的生活，要么通过摘水果、调酒、保姆或临时农场工作来边走边赚维持旅费。40% 的背包客来自英国，另有 30% 来自欧洲大陆。背包客是该国旅游业的重要组成部分，每年为澳大利亚经济贡献约 15 亿美元。在没有互联网的年代，背包客依靠口耳相传来规划行程。知识在旅行者之间传递：最佳旅游目的地、应避开的区域以及从一个地方到另一个地方的最便宜方式。青年旅舍里张贴的公告栏为寻找旅伴或希望分摊交通费用的游客提供了宝贵的资源，许多背包客结伴同行以削减成本并结交新朋友。火车和公共汽车是常见的交通方式，但许多经济型旅行者也会购买更便宜的二手车，以便按自己的节奏游览更多地方。虽然这种做法经常受到非议，但搭便车提供了另一种受欢迎的交通方式。对于预算紧张的人来说，搭便车提供了一种便宜、便捷的出行方式，同时也让游客能够结识当地人，并通过居住在那里的人了解他们正在穿越南北的地区。尽管警察强烈反对这种危险的做法，许多雇主也建议卡车司机不要搭载搭便车的人，但在 90 年代，这是旅行者出行的常见方式。
A free book titled The Budget Travellers Guidebook was available in hostels throughout New South Wales providing information written by backpackers for backpackers. It listed the Hume Highway as an ideal and popular hitchhiking spot for those looking to travel south from Sydney to Melbourne, noting the Liverpool train station as a good starting point. The guidebook advised, hitchhiking is generally safe and legal if you stand in a sensible spot. Solo guys and couples have a good chance of a lift. Make a destination sign and have your backpack visible. Women should not hitchhike alone. 19-year-old James Gibson was one of many young travellers who favoured hitchhiking as a mode of transit. Described as friendly, free-spirited, impulsive and somewhat nomadic, James was most passionate about two things in life, art and the environment. He took conservation issues seriously and was dedicated to saving the planet by attending wilderness walks, volunteering in the country fire service and participating in anti-logging protests. His dedication to the cause had recently led him to hitchhike from his family home on Victoria's Mornington Peninsula to a protest in the New South Wales town of Nimbun. Upon his return home, James was happy to be reunited with his family, of whom he was very close to. Yet, the nomadic lifestyle called to him and he soon found himself eager to hit the road again.
新南威尔士州的青年旅舍里提供一本名为《预算旅行者指南》的免费书籍，其中包含了由背包客为背包客撰写的信息。书中将休姆公路列为那些希望从悉尼向南前往墨尔本的人理想且热门的搭便车地点，并指出利物浦火车站是一个不错的起点。该指南建议：“如果您站在合理的位置，搭便车通常是安全且合法的。独自旅行的男性和情侣搭到顺风车的几率很高。制作一个目的地标志并让您的背包显眼。女性不应独自搭便车。”19 岁的詹姆斯·吉布森是喜欢以搭便车作为交通方式的众多年轻旅行者之一。詹姆斯被描述为友好、崇尚自由、冲动且有些四海为家，他生命中最热衷的两件事是艺术和环境。他认真对待自然保护问题，通过参加荒野徒步、在乡村消防局做志愿者以及参与反砍伐森林抗议活动来致力于拯救地球。他对这项事业的奉献最近促使他从位于维多利亚州莫宁顿半岛的家人住所搭便车前往新南威尔士州宁宾镇参加抗议活动。回到家后，詹姆斯很高兴能与他非常亲密的家人团聚。然而，这种游牧般的生活方式召唤着他，他很快发现自己渴望再次踏上旅程。
He decided to defer the sculpture course he had enrolled in at Frankston Tafe to have one more adventure. Although he was happy travelling alone, James invited his girlfriend Deborah Everest to join him on the trip. The two had met earlier that year at the beginning of 1989, where they had hit it off immediately despite their many differences. Deborah Everest was a bubbly and vivacious 19-year-old noted for her dry, mischievous sense of humour. A budding writer and avid reader, she was studying psychology at Melbourne's Monash University while working part-time for charity organisation The Quadriplegic Society. Deborah intended to eventually make the move into journalism. She had been living away from home while attending uni, but as 1989 drew to an end, she deferred her studies and returned to her family home in suburban Frankston to help take care of her father after he was diagnosed with cancer. Deborah planned to return to university the following year, but with her studies temporarily on hold, she was free to join James on his journey. Although she didn't share the same nomadic hippie traits as her boyfriend and much preferred home comforts, Deborah had never travelled before and thought it would do her good to take a break and broaden her horizons. James and Deborah made a plan to travel north to Sydney, where they would catch up with some of James' friends before the group would head back south together to Albury, a regional city on the New South Wales-Victorian border. There, they'd make their way to the small riverside town of Walwa to attend Confest, a bush camping festival that celebrates alternative lifestyles, offering workshops, live music and vegetarian food.
他决定推迟在弗兰克斯顿技术与继续教育学院报名的雕塑课程，再去进行一次冒险。尽管他很享受独自旅行，詹姆斯还是邀请了他的女友黛博拉·埃弗雷斯加入他的旅程。两人于当年早些时候（1989 年初）相遇，尽管他们有许多差异，但他们一拍即合。黛博拉·埃弗雷斯是一位性格开朗、活泼的 19 岁女孩，以其冷幽默和恶作剧式的幽默感而闻名。作为一名崭露头角的作家和狂热的读者，她在墨尔本的莫纳什大学攻读心理学，同时为慈善机构“四肢瘫痪者协会”兼职工作。黛博拉原本打算最终转行从事新闻工作。上大学期间她一直离家居住，但随着 1989 年接近尾声，她推迟了学业，返回弗兰克斯顿郊区的家中，以便在父亲被诊断出患有癌症后照顾他。黛博拉计划第二年重返大学，但在学业暂时搁置期间，她可以自由地加入詹姆斯的旅程。尽管她没有像男友那样四海为家的嬉皮士特质，而且更喜欢家庭的舒适，但黛博拉此前从未旅行过，她认为休息一下并开阔眼界对自己有好处。詹姆斯和黛博拉计划向北前往悉尼，在那里他们会与詹姆斯的一些朋友会合，然后一行人将一起向南返回阿尔伯里——新南威尔士州和维多利亚州边境的一个区域城市。在那里，他们将前往河畔小镇瓦尔瓦参加“音乐节”，这是一个庆祝另类生活方式的丛林露营节，提供工作坊、现场音乐和素食。
On the morning of December 28, 1989, James and Deborah's parents respectively dropped their children off at the Frankston train station. James told his mother the pair intended to hitchhike from Melbourne to Sydney via the Hume Highway, and she wasn't happy about the idea. Although her son was a gregarious and experienced traveller, she was aware of the dangers of hitchhiking and warned her son to be careful. James reassured his mother that hitchhiking was perfectly safe, as long as he didn't travel alone, so she had nothing to worry about, considering Deborah would be by his side. Unlike James, Deborah didn't tell her mother they planned on hitchhiking, instead explaining they were catching a train to Melbourne and would then be getting a lift to Sydney with some friends. At around 9am, James and Deborah farewelled their parents, purchased their tickets and boarded the train to Melbourne. James had packed his red with blue trim Berghaus brand backpack full of clothes, as well as a small camping stove and a 35mm Ricoh brand SLR camera his parents had given him earlier that year. Deborah was equipped with a green nylon sports bag packed with clothes and personal items, a green and beige sleeping bag that she had taken from her brother without asking, and $60 in cash.
1989 年 12 月 28 日清晨，詹姆斯和黛博拉的父母分别将各自的孩子送到弗兰克斯顿火车站。詹姆斯告诉母亲，两人打算经由休姆公路从墨尔本搭便车去悉尼，而她对这个想法并不高兴。尽管她的儿子是一个热情且经验丰富的旅行者，但她意识到了搭便车的危险，并警告儿子要小心。詹姆斯向母亲保证搭便车绝对安全，只要他不是独自旅行，所以她没有什么好担心的，因为黛博拉会陪在他身边。与詹姆斯不同，黛博拉并没有告诉母亲他们计划搭便车，而是解释说他们正乘火车去墨尔本，然后会和一些朋友一起搭车去悉尼。上午 9 点左右，詹姆斯和黛博拉与父母告别，买好票并登上了去墨尔本的火车。詹姆斯收拾了一个带有蓝色饰边的红色巴古斯牌背包，里面装满了衣服，还有一个小型露营炉以及父母在当年早些时候送给他的一台 35 毫米理光牌单反相机。黛博拉则携带了一个装有衣服和个人物品的绿色尼龙运动包，一个她未经允许从哥哥那里拿来的绿米相间睡袋，以及 60 美元现金。
The duo disembarked the train in Melbourne City and quickly succeeded in obtaining a ride northwards to Sydney. It was the summer holidays, so there was plenty of traffic on the road, and it was easy to get a lift. James and Deborah made the long journey north without any hiccups and arrived in Sydney as planned. Upon their arrival at James's friend's house in the inner city suburb of Surrey Hills, they discovered the group they were supposed to be meeting there had already left for Confest without them. Their trip to Sydney was now pointless as James and Deborah had specifically travelled an additional six hours north to join up with the Confest group. A little frustrated but accepting the situation, James and Deborah decided to stay the night in Sydney before making the six hour journey back south to Confest in the morning. James' friend's flatmate invited them to sleep on the lounge room floor before they departed for Orbury the next day. That night, December 29, Deborah phoned her mother to say,
两人在墨尔本市下车，并迅速成功搭上了向北前往悉尼的顺风车。当时正值暑假，路上车流量很大，搭车很容易。詹姆斯和黛博拉顺利完成了向北的长途旅行，按计划抵达了悉尼。当他们抵达位于内城萨里山郊区的詹姆士朋友家时，他们发现本应在那里会合的小组已经先于他们前往了音乐节。他们去悉尼的行程现在变得毫无意义，因为詹姆斯和黛博拉特意向北多行驶了六个小时，就是为了跟音乐节小组会合。虽然有些沮丧，但接受了现实，詹姆斯和黛博拉决定在悉尼过夜，第二天一早再向南行驶六个小时赶往音乐节。詹姆斯朋友的室友邀请他们在第二天出发去奥尔伯里之前睡在客厅的地板上。那天晚上，即 12 月 29 日，黛博拉给母亲打电话说：
We've arrived safely. I knew you would be in a panic until you heard from me. We're fine. Don't worry. I'll send you a postcard and we'll ring you tomorrow. James and Deborah set out for Orbury the following morning of December 30 at around 10am. They intended to follow the well-worn Backpackers path which involved catching a train to either Liverpool or Kasula in Sydney's south-west before heading towards the Hume Highway on foot and then attempting to hitch a ride south from a passing motorist. However, the exact route they ultimately decided to take is unknown. That day, Deborah's mother, Patricia Everest, waited eagerly for a phone call from her daughter as promised. But the evening came and went and there was no word from Deborah. Even though it was unlike Deborah not to be in touch, Patricia tried to reassure herself that the travelling couple were probably just having such a great time that they forgot to call home.
“我们安全到达了。我知道在你听到我的消息之前一定会惊慌失措。我们很好。别担心。我会给你寄一张明信片，我们明天给你打电话。”第二天（即 12 月 30 日）上午 10 点左右，詹姆斯和黛博拉动身前往奥尔伯里。他们打算沿着那条备受背包客喜爱的路线：乘火车前往悉尼西南部的利物浦或卡苏拉，然后步行前往休姆公路，接着尝试向南搭乘过往司机的顺风车。然而，他们最终选择的具体路线不得而知。那天，黛博拉的母亲帕特里夏·埃弗雷斯焦急地等待着女儿如约打来的电话。但傍晚来来去去，却没有黛博拉的任何消息。尽管黛博拉不联系家人很不符合她的习惯，但帕特里夏还是试图安慰自己，认为这对旅行的情侣可能只是玩得太开心以至于忘记给家里打电话了。
As the days went by and still she hadn't heard from her daughter, Patricia became increasingly concerned. She contacted James' mother, Peg Gibson, who advised she hadn't received any contact from her son. Peg wasn't too worried though. She was used to James venturing off to remote locations where there were limited means of communication. So she assured Patricia their children were probably just in an area with no telephone access. But as the days continued to pass by and still there was no word from James or Deborah, Peg began to share Patricia's concern. The two mothers kept in close contact, see if the other had heard anything. But when no news came through, they soon became frantic. On January 15, 1990, two weeks since Deborah's last phone call home,
随着日子一天天过去，依然没有女儿的消息，帕特里夏越来越担心。她联系了詹姆斯的母亲佩格·吉布森，佩格称她没有收到儿子的任何联系。不过，佩格并不是很担心。她习惯了詹姆斯动不动就去那些通信手段有限的偏远地区。因此她向帕特里夏保证，他们的孩子可能只是在一个没有电话信号的地区。但随着日子一天天过去，詹姆斯或黛博拉依然杳无音信，佩格也开始和帕特里夏一样担忧起来。两位母亲保持着密切联系，看看对方是否有任何消息。但当迟迟没有消息传来时，她们很快变得惊慌失措。1990 年 1 月 15 日，距离黛博拉给家里打最后一通电话已经过去了两周，
Patricia Everest and Peg Gibson made their way to the Frankston police station together, where they reported their two children missing. An officer entered James and Deborah's names into the missing person's register, noting that although James was known at times to live a somewhat nomadic lifestyle, he was also a responsible young man, and it was out of character for either of them not to be in contact with their families. Police took the report seriously, but it wasn't seen as a priority, as the officers deemed it likely the 19-year-olds had simply gotten swept up on an adventure and would call home soon. Patricia and Peg knew such behaviour would be out of character for their children, but tried to find comfort in the possibility. James's sister's wedding day was fast approaching, and the Gibson and Everest families held onto hopes the pair would return home in time for the occasion.
帕特里夏·埃弗雷斯和佩格·吉布森一同前往弗兰克斯顿警察局，报案称她们的两个孩子失踪了。警员将詹姆斯和黛博拉的名字录入了失踪人口登记册，并指出尽管詹姆斯有时过着某种四海为家的游牧生活，但他也是个负责任的年轻人，而且他们俩任何一个人不与家人联系都是很不正常的行为。警方认真对待了这份报案，但并未将其视为优先事项，因为警官认为这两个 19 岁的年轻人很可能只是沉浸在冒险中，很快就会给家里打电话。帕特里夏和佩格知道这种行为不符合她们孩子的性格，但还是试图在这种可能性中寻找慰藉。詹姆斯的姐姐的婚礼日即将来临，吉布森和埃弗雷斯家族都怀抱希望，期待两人能及时赶回家参加这一盛事。
James and his sister were close, and his family knew there was no way he would miss such a milestone event. But the big day on January 21 came and went with no contact from James or Deborah. Their families had no doubt now that something was horribly wrong. Friends and relatives gathered together to help with the search. Wearing t-shirts asking for information, they stopped at all the towns, truck stops, service stations and rest stops up and down the Hume Highway. They distributed posters featuring James and Deborah's photographs with the bold title missing, advising anyone with information about the duo's whereabouts to contact the police. Despite these efforts, days turned into months, and still there were no sightings and no word from James or Deborah.
詹姆斯和他的姐姐关系很近，他的家人知道他绝不可能错过这样的大事。然而，1 月 21 日的大日子在没有詹姆斯或黛博拉任何联系的情况下过去了。他们的家人现在毫不怀疑有什么可怕的事情发生了。朋友和亲戚们聚在一起协助搜寻。他们穿着印有寻人信息的 T 恤，在休姆公路沿线的所有城镇、卡车司机休息站、服务站和休息区停驻。他们分发印有詹姆斯和黛博拉照片的海报，上面醒目地写着“失踪”，并建议任何掌握两人下落信息的人联系警方。尽管付出了这些努力，但日子一天天变成月，依然没有任何关于詹姆斯或黛博拉的目击报告或消息。
On March 13, 1990, a woman named Wendy was driving along Galston Gorge Road, a narrow, picturesque stretch of asphalt road that runs between the towns of Hornsby and Dural in the northwest outskirts of Sydney. Wendy noticed a red backpack with blue trim on the side of the road and stopped to pick it up, throwing it in the boot of her car. When Wendy arrived to work, she had a look through the backpack that didn't find anything of interest. It contained a black pen, a tin of sardines and some pine needles, which she noted as odd considering there were no pine trees in Galston Gorge. She also noticed the ID tag had been cut out of the backpack, meaning there was no way of identifying its owner. So Wendy put the pack aside and went about her day. The next day, she had another look at the backpack and noticed there was a name, address and telephone number written inconspicuously on the bottom of the pack.
1990 年 3 月 13 日，一个名叫温迪的女人正开车行驶在加尔斯顿峡谷公路上，这是一段狭窄而风景如画的沥青路，位于悉尼西北郊区的霍恩斯比和杜拉之间。温迪注意到路边有一个带有蓝色饰边的红色背包，便停下车把它捡了起来，扔进了汽车后备箱。温迪到单位后，翻看了一下这个背包，但没有发现任何感兴趣的东西。里面有一支黑笔、一罐沙丁鱼和一些松针，她觉得这很奇怪，因为加尔斯顿峡谷没有松树。她还注意到背包上的身份标签被剪掉了，这意味着无法确认其所有者的身份。于是温迪把背包放在一边，继续忙她的工作。第二天，她又看了一眼背包，发现包底隐蔽处写着一个名字、地址和电话号码。
Alongside the phone number read the word Gibson. Wendy called the number and Peg Gibson answered, advising the backpack belonged to her son James, who had been missing along with his girlfriend Deborah for three and a half months. With this information, Wendy immediately drove to Hornsby police station and tanned the backpack in. After the discovery of the backpack, James and Deborah's disappearance started gaining more attention. Local newspaper The Hornsby Advocate ran a story about the missing couple, advising that James's backpack had now been located, but his Rico brand camera and Deborah's belongings were nowhere to be seen. The story sparked the attention of a local cyclist who had been riding his bike on Galston Gorge Road on December 31, 1989, the day after James and Deborah were last seen in Sydney. The cyclist found what appeared to be a near new 35mm Rico brand camera on the side of the road. Considering there was nothing on it to help identify its owner, the cyclist took the camera home and didn't give it much more thought.
电话号码旁边写着“吉布森”这个词。温迪拨打了这个号码，佩格·吉布森接了电话，称这个背包属于她的儿子詹姆斯，他已经和女友黛博拉失踪三个半月了。有了这些信息，温迪立刻开车去了霍恩斯比警察局，把背包上交了。背包被发现后，詹姆斯和黛博拉的失踪开始受到更多关注。当地报纸《霍恩斯比倡导者报》刊登了一篇关于这对失踪情侣的报道，称詹姆斯的背包现已被找到，但他的理光牌相机和黛博拉的物品却不见踪影。这则报道引起了一名当地骑行者的注意，他在 1989 年 12 月 31 日（即詹姆斯和黛博拉最后一次在悉尼被看到的第二天）曾骑自行车经过加尔斯顿峡谷公路。这位骑行者在路边发现了一个看起来几乎是全新的 35 毫米理光牌相机。考虑到上面没有任何东西可以帮助确定机主身份，骑行者就把相机带回了家，并没有过多去想它。
Now realising the camera might belong to missing backpacker James Gibson, he immediately handed it in to Hornsby police station. Members of James's family flew to Sydney and formally identified the backpack and the camera as belonging to the missing 19 year old. They were confused about the location in which the items were found. James and Deborah had plans to head south to Confest near Aubrey, so it made no sense that their belongings had shown up on the northwest outskirts of Sydney. Galston Gorge Road was about 45km northwest of Surrey Hills, the last place the couple were seen. Police appealed to witnesses who may have seen or picked up the couple to come forward, but to no success. In April, an extensive police search of the rugged Galston Gorge area was conducted, with police divers searching the river while 140 officers and emergency service personnel conducted a foot search along the winding Galston Gorge Road. Investigators remained open to all possibilities, including the hopeful that the pair had run away together after dumping their belongings.
现在意识到这台相机可能属于失踪的背包客詹姆斯·吉布森，他立刻将其上交到了霍恩斯比警察局。詹姆斯的家人们飞往悉尼，正式辨认出这个背包和相机属于这位失踪的 19 岁青年。他们对这些物品被发现的地点感到困惑。詹姆斯和黛博拉原本计划向南前往奥尔伯里附近的音乐节，所以他们的物品出现在悉尼西北郊区是完全说不通的。加尔斯顿峡谷公路距离这对情侣最后被看到的萨里山大约有 45 公里西北。警方呼吁曾看到过或接载过这对情侣的目击者站出来，但没有成功。四月份，警方对崎岖的加尔斯顿峡谷地区进行了大规模搜查，潜水员在河中搜寻，同时 140 名警官和应急服务人员沿着蜿蜒的加尔斯顿峡谷公路进行了徒步搜查。调查人员对所有可能性保持开放态度，包括充满希望的猜测：两人在丢下行李后一起私奔了。
To the sinister, that they fell to their deaths while climbing the cliffs, enacted a suicide pact, or had fallen victim to foul play. Given the fact that James and Deborah were both close with their families and had no prior history of self harm, accidental death or foul play were deemed the more likely of the worst case scenarios. Despite the extensive search efforts, no other items belonging to the couple were found. For Patricia Everest, the uncertainty of not knowing what happened to her daughter was the most painful aspect. Quote, The months continued to pass by and no new information came to light. James and Deborah's disappearance quickly faded from the news and had very little impact on other young travellers as the backpacking industry continued to thrive. 21 year old Simone Schmidel, known to friends as Simi, was bitten by the travel bug early.
也有阴暗的猜测：他们在攀登悬崖时不幸坠亡、实施了自杀契约，或者成为了谋杀的受害者。鉴于詹姆斯和黛博拉都与家人关系密切且没有自残前科，意外死亡或谋杀被认为是种种最坏情况中最有可能的。尽管进行了大规模的搜寻努力，但并未找到属于这对情侣的其他物品。对于帕特里夏·埃弗雷斯来说，不知道女儿发生了什么事的这种不确定性是最痛苦的方面。引述：“几个月继续过去，没有任何新信息浮出水面。詹姆斯和黛博拉的失踪很快从新闻中淡出，对其他年轻旅行者几乎没有产生什么影响，背包客行业依然蓬勃发展。21 岁的西蒙娜·施密德尔，朋友们叫她西米，很早就染上了旅游瘾。”
When she was 11 years old, she travelled with her family from their home country of Germany to Canada, which sparked her keen sense of adventure. After finishing high school, Simone headed to Yugoslavia, remarking to her friend, If I could afford it, I'd spend the rest of my life travelling around the world. It was a passion well suited to her fun, outgoing and trusting personality, which made her a confident jet setter. Two years after her trip to Yugoslavia, Simone visited Canada and Alaska for a camping holiday, where she met a number of fellow travellers, including several Australians. There was one person in particular she hit it off with, a young woman from Sydney named Christine Murphy, and Simone decided Australia would be her next destination. She considered it to be a safe and friendly country, much like Canada, and was eager to see the striking colours of the Great Barrier Reef and the endless desert horizon of the Aussie Outback. Simone returned home to Regensburg, a Bavarian city near Munich in Germany, working hard as a bookkeeper to save money for her upcoming Australian adventure.
当她 11 岁时，她和家人从家乡德国前往加拿大，这激发了她强烈的冒险精神。高中毕业后，西蒙娜前往南斯拉夫，对她的朋友说：“如果我负担得起，我会把余生都花在环游世界上。”这种热情非常适合她那有趣、外向和信任他人的性格，这使她成了一个自信的环球旅行者。在去南斯拉夫旅行两年后，西蒙娜前往加拿大和阿拉斯加进行了一次露营假期，在那里她遇到了许多同行旅行者，其中包括几个澳大利亚人。有一个人特别让她一见如故，那是来自悉尼的年轻女性克里斯蒂娜·墨菲，西蒙娜决定澳大利亚将是她的下一站。她认为这是一个安全且友好的国家，很像加拿大，并渴望看到大堡礁令人惊叹的色彩和澳大利亚内陆无尽的沙漠地平线。西蒙娜回到德国慕尼黑附近的巴伐利亚城市雷根斯堡，作为一名簿记员努力工作，为即将到来的澳大利亚冒险存钱。
Once Simone had successfully funded her trip, she went shopping with her father to buy the items required for her Australian camping holiday. She purchased a blue Salewa brand backpack adorned with a lilac pattern, a green and purple Salewa brand sleeping bag, a day pack and a cooking set. The Vowde brand Hogan model tent she wanted wasn't in stock, so the sales assistant had to order one in from the manufacturer. The tent arrived two weeks later, and Simone returned to the store to collect and sign for the item. Armed with everything she needed, Simone made her way to the Regensburg train station on September 29, 1990, where she planned to catch a train to Frankfurt before boarding her flight to Sydney. She was farewelled by her father, who urged his daughter to be careful, but Simone was more concerned about her father's wellbeing than her own, telling him, Take care and be careful that nothing happens to you. When I'm in Australia, I won't be able to help if something happens. During her flight to Sydney, Simone struck up a conversation with a fellow passenger and backpacker named Jeanette Muller, and the two became instant friends.
一旦西蒙娜成功筹集了旅费，她便和父亲去购物，购买澳大利亚露营假期所需的物品。她买了一个带有丁香花图案的蓝色萨利瓦牌背包、一个绿色和紫色的萨利瓦牌睡袋、一个小背包和一套炊具。她想要的瓦乌德牌霍根型号帐篷没有现货，所以销售助理不得不向制造商订购。帐篷两周后到达，西蒙娜回到店里领取并签署了物品签收单。带着她需要的一切，西蒙娜于 1990 年 9 月 29 日来到雷根斯堡火车站，计划在那里乘火车去法兰克福，然后登机飞往悉尼。她的父亲为她送行，并敦促女儿要小心，但西蒙娜比自己更担心父亲的健康，她对父亲说：“保重，小心别出什么事。当我在澳大利亚时，如果出事了我也帮不上忙。”在飞往悉尼的航班上，西蒙娜与同机乘客兼背包客珍妮特·穆勒交谈起来，两人瞬间成为了朋友。
As neither had any solid plans upon their arrival to Australia, they decided to travel together. Their first stop was a visit to Christine Murphy, whom Simone had met on her trip to Alaska. Simone and her new companion, Jeanette, arrived to Christine's house in the western Sydney suburb of Guildford, which they used as a base while exploring the city. After a week spent sightseeing, Simone and Jeanette caught a train to Liverpool and set out on foot down the Hume Highway, hitching a ride to Melbourne. From there, they bought a cheap car and drove north up to Queensland, before driving back to Melbourne to meet up with some friends. In Melbourne, the women sold their car and decided to hitchhike back to Sydney. They'd become very familiar with the Hume Highway during their travels and felt confident accepting rides along this well-trodden route. In Sydney, they stayed with Christine Murphy again, before flying to New Zealand. On January 19, 1991, Simone and Jeanette returned to Australia, where they crashed at Christine Murphy's Sydney-based house yet again.
由于两人抵达澳大利亚后都没有具体的计划，她们决定一起旅行。她们的第一站是拜访克里斯蒂娜·墨菲，西蒙娜是在去阿拉斯加旅行时认识她的。西蒙娜和她的新同伴珍妮特抵达了克里斯蒂娜位于悉尼西部吉尔福德郊区的家，她们以此为基地探索这座城市。经过一周的观光，西蒙娜和珍妮特乘火车前往利物浦，并步行沿着休姆公路出发，搭便车前往墨尔本。从那里，她们买了一辆便宜的车，向北开到昆士兰，然后开车回墨尔本与一些朋友会合。在墨尔本，两个女人卖掉了车，决定搭便车回悉尼。在旅行期间，她们对休姆公路已经非常熟悉，并且有信心在这条人迹罕至的路线沿途搭车。在悉尼，她们再次住在克里斯蒂娜·墨菲家，然后飞往新西兰。1991 年 1 月 19 日，西蒙娜和珍妮特返回澳大利亚，再次借住在克里斯蒂娜·墨菲位于悉尼的家中。
It was there that Simone announced the next leg of her trip. She planned to hitchhike on her own back down to Melbourne to meet her mother, who was flying over to join her on a campervan trip around the country. Simone's friends expressed worry over her plan to hitchhike alone. Christine felt Simone had already taken too many risks and should quit while she was ahead. Jeanette had done her fair share of hitchhiking with Simone, yet even she agreed that her travel companion should adopt a more cautious approach from here on out, believing the reason their previous efforts were safe and successful was due to the fact that they were travelling as a pair. Jeanette and Christine urged Simone to catch the bus to Melbourne instead, offering to buy her a ticket. Even Christine's mother warned Simone of the dangers of hitchhiking alone. But Simone shrugged it off, showing her a page from her travel guide that detailed Australia as a safe country to hitchhike. Simone had already made up her mind, as Christine Murphy described. Simone had a relaxed attitude towards hitchhiking, and told her friends not to worry. She'd always found people to be friendly and helpful. Her argument when we tried to talk her out of it was, don't worry about it, I'm quite safe.
正是在那里，西蒙娜宣布了她行程的下一阶段。她计划独自搭便车返回墨尔本，去接机她的母亲，后者将飞来与她一起进行房车环国旅行。西蒙娜的朋友们对她独自搭便车的计划表示担忧。克里斯蒂娜觉得西蒙娜已经冒了太多风险，应该见好就收。珍妮特曾和西蒙娜一起搭过不少次便车，然而连她也认为她的旅伴从现在开始应该采取更谨慎的方法，因为她相信她们以前的行动之所以安全且成功，是因为她们是结伴旅行的。珍妮特和克里斯蒂娜敦促西蒙娜改乘巴士去墨尔本，并主动提出为她买票。甚至克里斯蒂娜的母亲也警告西蒙娜独自搭便车的危险。但西蒙娜对此不以为然，向她展示了旅行指南上详细说明澳大利亚是一个适合搭便车的安全国家的页面。正如克里斯蒂娜·墨菲所描述的那样，西蒙娜已经下定了决心。西蒙娜对搭便车抱有一种放松的态度，并告诉她的朋友们不用担心。她一直发现人们很友好也很乐于助人。当我们试图劝阻她时，她的论点是：“不用担心，我很安全。”
At 8.30am on January 20, 1991, Simone Schmiddle left Christine Murphy's house to begin her solo journey to Melbourne. Jeanette walked her part way to the Guildford train station, where the two said they would buy us at a nearby news agency. The trains weren't running that morning, so Simone caught a bus from Guildford to Liverpool, where she began the walk to the Hume Highway at 9am. Simone's plan was to hold up a sign displaying her final destination of Melbourne in the hopes of catching a lift from a friendly truck driver. She set off down the Hume Highway wearing a bright yellow singlet, green shorts and hiking boots, carrying her backpack, tent, sleeping bag, and $20 cash. Three days later, on Wednesday, January 23, Simone's mother, her veneer, arrived at Melbourne Airport, eager to see her daughter after four months apart. However, Simone wasn't waiting for her mother in the arrivals lounge as expected. Her veneer assumed she wouldn't be too far away and continued to wait, wondering whether Simone had been confused about their plans.
1991 年 1 月 20 日上午 8 点 30 分，西蒙娜·施密德尔离开克里斯蒂娜·墨菲的家，开始她独自前往墨尔本的旅程。珍妮特陪她走了一段路到吉尔福德火车站，两人说她们要在附近的报社买车票。那天早上火车没有运行，所以西蒙娜乘坐巴士从吉尔福德到利物浦，并在上午 9 点开始步行前往休姆公路。西蒙娜的计划是举起一个显示她最终目的地是墨尔本的牌子，希望能搭上某位友善卡车司机的顺风车。她穿着一件明黄色的背心、绿色短裤和徒步靴，背着背包、帐篷、睡袋，带着 20 美元现金，踏上了休姆公路。三天后的 1 月 23 日星期三，西蒙娜的母亲赫维尼尔抵达了墨尔本机场，渴望在分开四个月后见到女儿。然而，西蒙娜并没有像预期那样在到达大厅等她的母亲。赫维尼尔以为她离得不远，便继续等待，心里琢磨着西蒙娜是不是搞混了她们的计划。
Perhaps she thought they were supposed to meet at the house of a friend where they would be staying. Her veneer called a taxi to their friend's house, presuming Simone was already there, but when she arrived, Simone was nowhere to be seen and nobody had heard from her. The worried mother sat by the phone, waiting for Simone to ring, but no calls came through. Her veneer called Christine Murphy's house the last place her daughter stayed. Simone's friends Christine and Jeanette had already begun to worry even before receiving her veneer's phone call. Simone had promised to make contact upon her safer arrival to Melbourne, but days had passed since she departed and they still hadn't heard a word from her. Christine said, By Monday night, when we hadn't heard from Simi, we began to worry.
也许她以为她们应该在一个朋友家里碰头并在那里暂住。赫维尼尔叫了一辆出租车去朋友家，以为西蒙娜已经在那里了，但当她到达时，西蒙娜不见踪影，也没有任何人听到过她的消息。这位担惊受怕的母亲守在电话旁，等待着西蒙娜的电话，但没有任何电话打进来。赫维尼尔给女儿呆过的最后一站——克里斯蒂娜·墨菲的家打了电话。西蒙娜的朋友克里斯蒂娜和珍妮特甚至在接到赫维尼尔的电话之前就已经开始担心了。西蒙娜曾承诺在安全抵达墨尔本后联系她们，但自从她出发以来已经过去了好几天，她们依然没有听到她的任何消息。克里斯蒂娜说：“到周一晚上，当我们还没有听到西米的任何消息时，我们开始担心了。”
By Tuesday night, logic began to hit. On the fifth day of Simone's disappearance, her veneer made her way to the Russell Street police station in Melbourne to report her daughter missing. The officers on duty weren't overly concerned. Simone was an experienced young backpacker and there was every chance she had made a spur of the moment decision to change her travel plans. But her veneer knew such a thing would be completely out of character for her daughter. When Simone's father Herbert was notified of his daughter's disappearance, he sought assistance from his local police station in Germany. The German officers told him there was nothing they could do as it was an issue for Australian police. Herbert explained he couldn't speak English and wanted their assistance gaining some more information.
到了周二晚上，理智开始让人清醒。在西蒙娜失踪的第五天，她的母亲赫维尼尔前往墨尔本的拉塞尔街警察局报案女儿失踪。值班警官并没有过分担心。西蒙娜是一位经验丰富的年轻背包客，她很有可能是临时起意改变了旅行计划。但赫维尼尔知道这种事对她的女儿来说是完全不可能的。当西蒙娜的父亲赫伯特被告知女儿失踪时，他向德国当地警察局寻求帮助。德国警官告诉他，他们无能为力，因为这是澳大利亚警方的事。赫伯特解释说他不会说英语，希望他们能协助获取更多信息。
But the German police advised him to find an English speaking friend or relative who could help instead. Herbert contacted the German Embassy in Canberra and higher authorities in German law enforcement, but they advised him to contact foreign affairs. Time and time again, his attempts to seek help led nowhere, made all the more difficult by the language barrier impacting his ability to communicate with Australian authorities. Her veneer stayed in Australia, holding out hopes that her daughter would show up. Overwhelmed with fear and anxiety, her veneer began suffering regular bouts of nausea. After six weeks of searching with no sign of Simone, she eventually returned to Germany alone. During a public appeal for anyone with information to come forward, Simone's travel companion Jeanette Muller said, People in Germany want to come to Australia because it's so far away, the great southern land.
但德国警察建议他去找一个会说英语的朋友或亲戚来帮忙。赫伯特联系了德国驻堪培拉大使馆和德国执法部门的高层当局，但他们建议他联系外交部。一次又一次，他寻求帮助的尝试都无果而终，语言障碍更是雪上加霜，影响了他与澳大利亚当局沟通的能力。赫维尼尔留在澳大利亚，抱着女儿会现身的希望。被恐惧和焦虑压得喘不过气来，赫维尼尔开始频繁感到恶心。经过六周毫无西蒙娜踪迹的搜寻后，她最终独自返回了德国。在一次呼吁知情者提供线索的公开呼吁中，西蒙娜的旅伴珍妮特·穆勒说：“德国人想来澳大利亚，因为它是那么遥远，那片伟大的南方大陆。”
But Australia is also well known for its great crime rate. My mother warned me about it before I left. Like the thousands of backpackers who were drawn to Australia each year, 21-year-old Gabor Neugebauer was eager to see as much of the world as possible. Born in Stuttgart, Germany, his father's job in the Air Force meant Gabor had moved around a lot throughout his childhood, so he felt confident venturing to new places, even though he was quiet, shy and liked to keep to himself. Passionate about nature and the environment, Gabor had a particular interest in geology and volcanology. After serving 15 months compulsory service in the German military, he applied to pursue these interests at university, but when he failed to gain entry to his preferred course, he enrolled in a philosophy degree instead.
但澳大利亚也因其高犯罪率而闻名。我离开前我妈妈就警告过我。”就像每年被吸引到澳大利亚的成千上万名背包客一样，21 岁的加博尔·诺伊盖鲍尔渴望尽可能多地看世界。加博尔出生于德国斯图加特，父亲在空军的工作意味着加博尔在童年时期搬过很多次家，所以他对探索新地方感到自信，尽管他性格安静、害羞且喜欢独处。加博尔对自然和环境充满热情，对地质学和火山学有着特别的兴趣。在德国军队服役 15 个月义务兵役后，他申请在大学里继续深造这些兴趣，但当他未能被心仪的专业录取时，他转而注册了哲学学位。
He promised his parents he would transfer to something they considered more serious once he had scratched his travel itch. It was around this time that Gabor met Anya Habsheed, a shy, kind-hearted 20-year-old who shared his love for the environment. Anya had recently completed a drafting course and was eager to embrace the world beyond Germany before she recommenced her studies. Beyond their shared passions for nature and travel, Anya and Gabor had lots in common, neither smoked or drank, and both embraced an easygoing attitude towards life. The two set off on their first adventure together around Europe at the start of 1991. At over 6 feet tall, Gabor towered over Petit Anya, and his fit, strong physique ensured she felt safe travelling in his company. The couple enjoyed their European travel experience so much that upon their return, they began planning their next trip right away.
他向父母保证，一旦他的旅游瘾过去，他就会转到一个他们认为更严肃的专业。正是在这段时间里，加博尔遇到了安妮·哈布希德，一个害羞、心地善良的 20 岁女孩，她有着和他一样的环保爱好。安妮最近刚完成了一门绘图课程，渴望在重新开始学业之前拥抱德国以外的世界。除了对大自然和旅行的共同热爱之外，安妮和加博尔有很多共同点：两人都不抽烟也不喝酒，并且都对生活抱有一种随遇而安的态度。两人于 1991 年初开始了他们在欧洲的第一次冒险之旅。加博尔身高超过 6 英尺，比娇小的安妮高出许多，他健硕强壮的体格确保了安妮在与他同行时感到安全。这对情侣非常享受他们的欧洲旅行体验，以至于刚一回来，他们就开始着手规划下一趟旅程。
Gabor's uni course was scheduled to resume in early 1992, and before returning to the books, He and Anya decided to set off on a two-month journey backpacking around Asia, where they were mostly looking forward to visiting the temples and volcanoes of Indonesia. They set off for Indonesia in late 1991, but while they were there, the weather took an unexpected turn for the worse, and the couple made a spur-of-the-moment decision to head to Australia instead. Gabor and Anya landed in Darwin in December 1991, before venturing to the tropical city of Cairns in far north Queensland. With Christmas fast approaching, they met some other travellers along the way who told them Bondi Beach in Sydney was the place to be during the festive season, as there was a large backpackers' Christmas party put on there every year.
加博尔的大学课程计划于 1992 年初恢复，在重返书本之前，他和安妮决定开启为期两个月的亚洲背包客之旅，他们最期待的是参观印度尼西亚的寺庙和火山。他们在 1991 年底动身前往印度尼西亚，但在他们呆在那里的时候，天气发生了意想不到的恶劣变化，这对情侣临时决定改道前往澳大利亚。加博尔和安妮于 1991 年 12 月在达尔文着陆，随后前往昆士兰州远北的热带城市凯恩斯。随着圣诞节的临近，他们在途中遇到了一些其他旅行者，他们告诉他们，悉尼的邦迪海滩是节日期间必去的地方，因为那里每年都会举办大型的背包客圣诞派对。
Intrigued by this tip, the couple added Sydney to their itinerary, with Anya writing a letter to her family in Germany saying she was really looking forward to this leg of their journey. Upon their arrival in Sydney, Gabor and Anya checked into a hostel in Kings Cross, an inner-city district which at the time was a hotbed for drugs, crime and seedy nightlife, but was popular with backpackers due to the cheap accommodation available. Not liking the vibes of the city and unable to sleep during the hot, sticky summer night, Gabor called his family in Germany from a payphone in the hostel corridor at 4am on Christmas morning. Although the international connection was poor, Gabor's mother could tell her son wasn't in good spirits.
这对情侣对这个建议很感兴趣，便将悉尼加入了他们的行程中。安娅写信给德国的家人，说她非常期待旅程的这一段。抵达悉尼后，加博尔和安娅入住位于国王十字区的一家旅舍。国王十字区是当时市中心的一个毒品、犯罪和低俗夜生活滋生的地方，但由于住宿便宜，深受背包客的欢迎。由于不喜欢这个城市的氛围，又在闷热潮湿的夏夜难以入眠，加博尔在圣诞节早晨4点从旅舍走廊的公用电话打回德国的家。虽然国际长途信号很差，但加博尔的母亲还是听出儿子情绪不高。
He and Anya much preferred Asia over Australia and were looking forward to leaving. Before the phone line disconnected, Gabor told his mother he wanted to leave Australia as soon as possible. The next day, December 26, 1991, Gabor and Anya settled their bill and checked out of the Kings Cross hostel, telling staff they were heading north to Darwin. They had booked a flight to Indonesia departing New Year's Day and were eager to resume that portion of their trip before flying from Indonesia to Germany on January 14. However, January 14 came and went and nobody back home heard a word from Anya or Gabor, nor had they returned to Germany as planned.
他和安娅比起澳大利亚明显更喜欢亚洲，并且很期盼离开。在电话挂断之前，加博尔告诉母亲他想尽快离开澳大利亚。第二天，即1991年12月26日，加博尔和安娅结清了账单，退出了国王十字区的旅舍，并告诉工作人员他们要向北前往达尔文。他们预订了一张元旦出发去印度尼西亚的机票，渴望在从印尼飞回德国（1月14日）之前，先完成那部分的行程。然而，1月14日来了又去，老家的任何人都没有收到安娅或加博尔的半点音讯，他们也没有按计划返回德国。
Their families clung to the possibility that they may have simply missed their flight or had decided to extend their stay and weren't able to reach a phone to let anyone know. But fees for their well-being were quickly exacerbated when it was revealed Gabor and Anya hadn't touched over $3,000 worth of travellers checks since checking out of their Kings Cross hostel. Knowing they would be returning to Darwin after Sydney, Gabor and Anya had let their friends and family know to direct any mail for them to the Darwin Post Office. It was common practice for backpackers who had no fixed address to nominate a post office where they could collect mail while passing through.
他们的家人紧紧抓住一丝希望，认为他们可能只是错过了航班，或者决定延长停留时间却找不到电话通知大家。但随着事情的发展，关于他们安危的担忧迅速加剧，因为据透露，加博尔和安娅自离开国王十字区旅舍以来，根本没有动过价值3000多美元的旅行支票。明知离开悉尼后会返回达尔文，加博尔和安娅曾让亲友将任何信件直接寄往达尔文邮局。对于没有固定地址的背包客来说，指定一个邮局以便在路过时领取信件是很常见的做法。
Gabor's mother had sent a couple a Christmas package containing cookies and other treats, but the package remained at the Darwin Post Office uncollected, indicating the couple may have never made it there. On January 30, 1992, a little over a month since Anya and Gabor were last seen checking out of the hostel in Sydney, their disappearance was reported to German police. The report was forwarded on to the Australian Federal Police who immediately began looking into the case, yet they uncovered very little information to suggest what had happened to the couple. Gabor and Anya's families hired a private investigator, but they too failed to find any trace of the two young backpackers. After months of searching and no leads, it was as though they had simply vanished into thin air.
加博尔的母亲曾给这对情侣寄过一个装有饼干和其他零食的圣诞包裹，但这个包裹一直无人领取地留在达尔文邮局，这表明这对情侣可能根本没有去过那里。1992年1月30日，距离安娅和加博尔最后一次被看到离开悉尼旅舍仅一个多月，他们的失踪被报告给了德国警方。这份报告被转交给澳大利亚联邦警察，后者立即开始着手调查此案，然而他们几乎没有发现任何能说明这对情侣遭遇了什么的信息。加博尔和安娅的家人雇了一名私家侦探，但也未能找到这两位年轻背包客的任何踪迹。经过几个月的搜寻却没有任何线索，他们就像是凭空消失了一样。
Frustrated with the fruitless investigation, Gabor's parents, Ankar and Manfred Neugebauer, along with Anya's brother Norbert, decided to head to Australia to initiate their own search. They were convinced the couple may have been involved in an accident and were eager to increase the media attention to see if anyone came forward with information. Ankar, Manfred and Norbert arrived in Sydney in April 1992, meeting with the New South Wales police force and conducting several press conferences. For Norbert, his sister's disappearance was completely out of character,
面对毫无进展的调查，加博尔的父母安卡和曼弗雷德·诺伊格鲍尔，以及安娅的兄弟诺伯特，感到十分沮丧，他们决定前往澳大利亚展开自己的搜寻。他们确信这对情侣可能遭遇了意外，并渴望增加媒体关注度，看看是否有人能提供线索。安卡、曼弗雷德和诺伯特于1992年4月抵达悉尼，与新南威尔士州警方会面并召开了多次新闻发布会。对诺伯特来说，他妹妹的失踪极其反常，
as he knew she was looking forward to returning to Germany to resume her studies. He told the media, we decided the only way to know what was happening was to come here to look for ourselves. For us, there are only a few possibilities. If someone is murdered, the first thing you do is steal their money, but no checks have been cashed. They could have had an accident, fallen over a cliff, but nobody has seen it. We know they would contact us if they could.
因为他知道她非常渴望返回德国继续学业。他告诉媒体：“我们决定弄清楚发生了什么事的唯一方法就是亲自来这里寻找。对我们来说，只有几种可能。如果有人被谋杀，你做的第一件事就是偷他们的钱，但没有任何支票被兑现。他们可能遭遇了意外，从悬崖上摔了下来，但没有人看到。我们知道如果可以的话，他们一定会联系我们的。”
The media attention was helpful in generating public awareness, with the police receiving over 200 tip-offs from witnesses who believed they had sighted the couple. Every lead was followed, but each went nowhere, with the sightings believed to be a case of mistaken identity. Ankar, Manfred and Norbert decided to follow the trail Anya and Gabor had taken, but were faced with the problem that no one knew 100% which way the couple had travelled after leaving Sydney. Although their flight from Darwin to Indonesia had been scheduled to leave just six days later, Gabor had told his parents they were heading south down the Hume Highway,
媒体的关注对提高公众意识很有帮助，警方收到了来自200多名目击者的线索，这些目击者都认为自己看到了这对情侣。每一条线索都被跟进，但都无果而终，这些目击事件被认为是一场认错人的乌龙。安卡、曼弗雷德和诺伯特决定沿着安娅和加博尔走过的路线寻找，但他们面临一个问题：没有人百分之百确定这对情侣离开悉尼后走的是哪条路。尽管他们从达尔文飞往印度尼西亚的航班原定于短短六天后起飞，但加博尔曾告诉父母他们正沿着休姆高速公路向南行驶，
making their way to Victoria, specifically Mildura, a historical country town on the banks of the Murray River. From there, the couple would visit Adelaide in the neighbouring state of South Australia, before heading north through the outback on the Stuart Highway to their final destination of Darwin. But this contradicted reports from the King's Cross Hostel Staff in Sydney, who were adamant Gabor and Anya said they were taking the north route via Queensland towards Darwin, as they had asked for hostel recommendations in that direction. Ankar, Manfred and Norbert spent the next five weeks travelling through Australia in a camper van. They decided to follow the advice from the King's Cross Hostel Staff and head north from Sydney.
前往维多利亚州，具体是墨累河畔的历史乡村小镇米尔杜拉。从那里，这对情侣将参观邻近南澳大利亚州的阿德莱德，然后通过斯图尔特高速公路向北穿过内陆，到达他们的最终目的地达尔文。但这与悉尼国王十字区旅舍员工的说法相矛盾，后者坚信加博尔和安娅曾说他们要经由昆士兰走北部路线前往达尔文，因为他们曾询问过那个方向的旅舍推荐。安卡、曼弗雷德和诺伯特在接下来的五周里开着一辆露营车在澳大利亚旅行。他们决定听从国王十字区旅舍员工的建议，从悉尼向北进发。
Going to Brisbane, Townsville, Mount Isa, Darwin, Alice Springs, Port Augusta and Broken Hill. They visited every hostel, cafe and local store they could, asking if anyone had seen the missing backpackers. After covering over 10,000 kilometres without finding a single trace of Anya or Gabor, the desperate trio visited a clairvoyant on their final day in Australia, who told them, Your children are no longer alive. Your son died very quickly, but his friend Anya suffered terribly before she died. Gabor, Noigabour and Anya Habsheed's disappearance came almost two years to the day after James Gibson and Deborah Everest were last seen in Surrey Hills, and just 11 months since Simone Schmiddle was last seen walking down the Hume Highway near Liverpool.
他们去了布里斯班、汤斯维尔、伊萨山、达尔文、艾丽斯斯普林斯、奥古斯塔港和布罗肯希尔。他们走访了所有能找到的旅舍、咖啡馆和当地商店，询问是否有人见过失踪的背包客。在行程超过10000公里却连安娅或加博尔的一丝踪迹都没找到后，这个绝望的三人组在他们澳大利亚之行的最后一天拜访了一位灵媒，灵媒告诉他们：“你们的孩子已经不在了。你们的儿子死得很快，但他的朋友安娅在死前遭受了可怕的折磨。”加博尔和安娅·哈布希德的失踪几乎正好发生在詹姆斯·吉布森和黛博拉·埃弗里斯特最后一次在萨里山被看到的两年后，也是西蒙娜·施米德尔最后一次被看到在利物浦附近的休姆高速公路上行走后的短短11个月。
Although all three cases involved young travellers disappearing in Sydney, there was no evidence to link them in any way, and nothing that made them stand out for police amongst all of the other active missing person cases. In Australia in the early 90s, 24,000 people were reported missing each year, a majority of those reported missing either reappeared or were found within the first two weeks, but 300 missing people remained unaccounted for each year. James Gibson, Deborah Everest, Simone Schmiddle, Gabor Noigabour and Anya Habsheed joined the thousands of names of persons who had disappeared without a trace. During a missing persons week appeal for information,
尽管这三起案件都涉及年轻旅行者在悉尼失踪，但没有任何证据将它们以任何方式联系起来，也没有什么能让警方在所有其他未破的失踪人口案件中对它们格外关注。在90年代初的澳大利亚，每年有24000人被报告失踪，其中绝大多数被报失踪的人要么重新出现，要么在头两周内被找到，但每年仍有300人下落不明。詹姆斯·吉布森、黛博拉·埃弗里斯特、西蒙娜·施米德尔、加博尔和安娅·哈布希德的名字，加入了数千名消失得无影无踪的人的行列。在一次寻找失踪人员信息的呼吁周期间，
a spokesperson for the New South Wales Police missing persons unit stated, We just cannot ever give up hope. We are constantly reviewing and re-reviewing our files. 22-year-old Joanne Walters had always dreamed of visiting Australia and New Zealand, destinations she considered far more exotic than her hometown of Mystig, near Cardiff, in Wales. Joanne had a humble life, growing up with a mother who worked as a shop assistant and father who worked in a paper mill factory. She was a model student at school, and her warm nature ensured others were drawn towards her. Having recently travelled through Europe, Joanne was looking forward to her next adventure.
新南威尔士州警察失踪人口部门的一位发言人表示：“我们绝不能放弃希望。我们一直在审查和重新审查我们的档案。”22岁的乔安妮·沃尔特斯一直梦想着访问澳大利亚和新西兰，她认为这些目的地比她位于威尔士加的夫附近的家乡米斯蒂格要异国情调得多。乔安妮过着简朴的生活，母亲是一名店员，父亲在造纸厂工作。她是学校里的模范学生，热情性格吸引着周围的人。乔安妮最近刚游历过欧洲，正期待着她的下一次冒险。
As she flipped through a newspaper, she noticed an advertisement offering two return flights to Australia for the price of one. Excited by the offer, she contacted her Scottish friend Pauline Reid whom she had met the previous year while travelling through Greece. The two decided to venture to the land down under for an extended working holiday, with Joanne promising to call and write home regularly. Joanne and Pauline arrived in Sydney in early June 1991, spending the next few weeks travelling north to Queensland before deciding to part ways and meet up again further down the track. Joanne returned to Sydney where she rented a flat in King's Cross with another backpacker and applied for a job as a nanny. She was one of 100 applicants for the nanny position, but for the Jensen family, Joanne was the ideal candidate. Sensible, independent and outgoing, they happily hired her for the job.
当她翻阅报纸时，她注意到一则广告，提供买一赠一的澳大利亚双人往返机票。被这个优惠吸引的她，联系了她的苏格兰朋友波琳·里德，两人是前一年在希腊旅游时认识的。两人决定冒险去遥远的南半球进行一次长假打工度假，乔安妮承诺会定期打电话和写信回家。乔安妮和波琳于1991年6月初抵达悉尼，在接下来的几周里向北旅行到昆士兰，然后决定分道扬镳，以后再聚。乔安妮返回悉尼，与另一名背包客在国王十字区租了一间公寓，并申请了一份保姆的工作。她是这份保姆工作的100名申请者之一，但对于詹森一家来说，乔安妮是理想的人选。她明智、独立又外向，他们很高兴地雇用了她。
Joanne loved being a nanny for the Jensens, spending her spare time visiting the sites of Sydney and mingling with other travellers and locals at various bars and cafes throughout the King's Cross area. It was during this time that Joanne crossed paths with another young female backpacker and the two immediately hit it off. 21-year-old Caroline Clark was a well-educated, determined young woman who enjoyed an upper middle-class upbringing in the county of Surrey in England, where she loved playing netball and hockey and socialising with her wide circle of friends. Always up for a laugh, Caroline had a knack for impersonating teachers, family members and celebrities to the amusement of others. Caroline was driven to make a difference in the world, applying for a job as a police officer at age 20. The recruitment officers at the Surrey Police Department thought her qualities made her a great candidate, but felt she was a little too young. They advised her to go out and gain more life experiences, then come back to see them again in a couple of years.
乔安妮非常喜欢为詹森一家当保姆，她把闲暇时间用来参观悉尼的名胜古迹，并在国王十字区周围的各种酒吧和咖啡馆里与同行旅客和当地人交往。正是在这段时间里，乔安妮结识了另一位年轻的女背包客，两人一拍即合。21岁的卡罗琳·克拉克是一个受过良好教育、意志坚定的年轻女性，她在英国萨里郡度过了一个优越的中产阶级童年，在那里她喜欢打无板篮球和曲棍球，并与她广泛的朋友圈社交。卡罗琳总是喜欢开玩笑，她有一种模仿老师、家庭成员和名人的天赋，常常逗乐别人。卡罗琳立志要在世界上做出一番改变，在20岁时申请了一名警察的职位。萨里警察局的招聘官认为她的特质使她成为一个很好的候选人，但觉得她稍微年轻了一点。他们建议她出去获得更多的人生阅历，然后在几年后再来找他们。
Caroline recognised this as a great opportunity to travel the world and started saving her money for an extended backpacking trip. Her older brother had recently travelled to Australia and had spoken so highly of his experience there that Caroline decided to add the destination to her bucket list. Caroline got a job as an assistant manager for a pizza restaurant, where she was well liked by customers and staff. After saving enough money, she spent a month travelling through Europe before making her way to Australia, where she planned to work and travel before passing through Indonesia and Thailand on her way home 18 months later. Joanne Walters had already been in Australia for four months when she met Caroline Clark. The two became instant friends and decided to embark on their further travels together. Although Joanne enjoyed nannying for the Jensen family, word from other backpackers was that fruit picking presented a great opportunity to see more of the country while learning a wage along the way.
卡罗琳认为这是一个环游世界的绝佳机会，并开始为一次长时间的背包客旅行攒钱。她的哥哥最近去过澳大利亚，对那里的经历赞不绝口，于是卡罗琳决定将这个目的地加入她的愿望清单。卡罗琳找到了一份披萨餐厅助理经理的工作，深受顾客和员工的喜爱。攒够钱后，她在欧洲旅行了一个月，然后前往澳大利亚，她计划在那里工作和旅行，18个月后在回家的路上经由印度尼西亚和泰国返回。乔安妮·沃尔特斯在遇到卡罗琳·克拉克时已经在澳大利亚呆了四个月。两人一见如故，决定结伴开启接下来的旅程。虽然乔安妮很享受为詹森一家当保姆，但其他背包客的消息说，摘水果提供了绝佳的机会，可以一边欣赏更多国家风光，一边沿途赚取工资。
Joanne ran the idea past Caroline, who agreed fruit picking sounded like a great idea, and the two decided to make their way to Miljura in regional Victoria, known for its grape production. The Jensen family were sad to see Joanne leave, but were understanding and supportive of her decision. In early February 1992, Joanne and Caroline set out for Miljura with two other backpackers they had met, catching a train to Liverpool before walking towards the Hume Highway. The foursome decided they'd have more success hitching a ride if they split into pairs, and the plan paid off. All four women made it to Miljura safely, where they each got to work picking grapes in a local vineyard. It was in Miljura that Joanne and Caroline struck up a friendship with an Englishman named Steve Wright,
乔安妮把这个想法告诉了卡罗琳，卡罗琳也觉得摘水果是个好主意，于是两人决定前往以葡萄生产闻名的维多利亚州地区米尔杜拉。詹森一家很难过看到乔安妮离开，但对她的决定表示理解和支持。1992年2月初，乔安妮和卡罗琳与她们遇到的另外两名背包客一起出发前往米尔杜拉，她们先乘火车到利物浦，然后步行走向休姆高速公路。这四个人决定如果分成两组，搭便车成功的几率会更高，这个计划果然奏效了。四位女性都安全到达了米尔杜拉，并在当地的一家葡萄园开始工作采摘葡萄。正是在米尔杜拉，乔安妮和卡罗琳结识了一位名叫史蒂夫·赖特的英国人，
and the trio decided to head to Tasmania together, as they'd heard it was a good spot to get work picking apples. When their job in Miljura was complete, they made a brief return to Sydney before once again hitching a ride down the Hume Highway to Melbourne, where they caught the ferry to Tasmania. The nights in Tasmania were much colder than the women expected, so Joanne purchased the blue and orange ultimate brand sleeping bag that was much warmer than the one she had originally brought with her. In Tasmania, Steve Wright decided to leave the women and go his separate way, but as he didn't plan on doing any more camping, he offered to swap his blue three-person tent for Joanne and Caroline's two-person tent. They were grateful for the exchange, as the tent they had been sleeping in was too small for the both of them.
三人决定一起前往塔斯马尼亚，因为他们听说那里是找苹果采摘工作的好地方。当他们在米尔杜拉的工作结束后，他们短暂返回悉尼，然后再次搭便车沿休姆高速公路前往墨尔本，在那里乘渡轮去了塔斯马尼亚。塔斯马尼亚的夜晚比女人们预期的要冷得多，因此乔安妮购买了蓝色和橙色终极品牌的睡袋，这比她最初带来要暖和得多。在塔斯马尼亚，史蒂夫·赖特决定离开女性朋友走自己的路，但由于他不打算再露营，他主动提出用他蓝色的三人帐篷交换乔安妮和卡罗琳的双人帐篷。她们对这次交换心存感激，因为她们一直睡的帐篷对她们两个人来说太小了。
They even overlooked the fact that Steve's tent had a hole in it, as he had patched it up with an adhesive label. After their apple-picking job came to an end, Joanne and Caroline departed Tasmania and returned to their Sydney-based hostel in Kings Cross. From there, they planned to venture to Western Australia, as they'd heard there was upcoming work available during the melon-picking season. They made a rough plan to slowly make their way there by driving along the scenic Great Ocean Road in Victoria to Adelaide, then proceed north to Uluru in the Northern Territories Desert, before finally reaching the Western Australian town of Kananara. On April 16, 1992, both Joanne and Caroline called their families back home to let them know their plans. They were both happy and in good spirits, looking forward to the next portion of their adventure, which was set to begin the following morning. The next day, they received a visit at the hostel from Pauline Reed, the friend who Joanne had originally travelled to Australia with.
她们甚至忽略了史蒂夫的帐篷上有个洞的事实，因为他用一个粘性标签补好了。苹果采摘工作结束后，乔安妮和卡罗琳离开塔斯马尼亚，返回她们位于悉尼国王十字区的旅舍。从那里，她们计划去西澳大利亚，因为她们听说那里在甜瓜采摘季节有工作机会。她们做了一个粗略的计划，打算通过沿着维多利亚州风景秀丽的大洋路开车到阿德莱德，然后向北前往北领地沙漠中的乌鲁鲁，最后到达西澳大利亚城镇卡纳纳拉，慢慢地前往目的地。1992年4月16日，乔安妮和卡罗琳都给家里的亲人打电话，告知他们的计划。她们都很开心，精神饱满，期待着定于第二天开始的下一段冒险。第二天，她们在旅舍接待了波琳·里德，也就是乔安妮最初同游澳大利亚的朋友。
They filled Pauline in on their travel itinerary, advising her they intended to get around by hitchhiking most of the way. They had hitched many rides already and had nothing but positive experiences so far, seeing it as a great way to meet friendly locals. Despite their plans, Joanne and Caroline were quite unorganised and the day quickly got away from them. As the afternoon descended into twilight, they decided to put their trip off until the next day, as the idea of hitchhiking at night held a very little appeal. At 7.30am on April 18, 1992, Joanne and Caroline spoke with Steve Wright, the backpacker with whom they had previously travelled to Tasmania with. They advised him they were taking the same route down the Hume Highway they had taken previously when hitching to Miljura and Melbourne. They planned to catch a train from King's Cross to Kassoula, the station after Liverpool, then make the short walk to the Hume Highway from where they had hitched their first lift. It was a beautiful day and the sun was shining as Steve farewelled his friends and wished them luck.
她们向波琳介绍了她们的旅行行程，告知她她们打算一路上主要靠搭便车出行。她们已经搭过很多次便车，到目前为止只有积极的体验，认为这是结识友善当地人的好方法。尽管有这样的计划，乔安妮和卡罗琳相当没有条理，时间很快就过去了。随着下午转入黄昏，她们决定把行程推迟到第二天，因为晚上搭便车几乎没什么吸引力。1992年4月18日上午7点30分，乔安妮和卡罗琳与史蒂夫·赖特交谈，史蒂夫是她们之前一起去过塔斯马尼亚的背包客。她们告诉他，她们将走与之前去米尔杜拉和墨尔本时相同的休姆高速公路路线。她们计划从国王十字区乘火车到卡苏拉，即利物浦之后的那个车站，然后步行一小段路到她们第一次搭便车的休姆高速公路。那是一个阳光明媚的美丽日子，史蒂夫向朋友们告别并祝他们好运。
Two weeks later, Joanne's parents in Wales felt uneasy when they hadn't heard a word from their daughter. Joanne was a dutiful child who called and wrote letters home on a regular basis, keeping her parents in the loop of her next contactable address. It was very unlike her to be out of touch, but they gave their daughter the benefit of their doubt, hoping she was just having too much fun or was currently travelling through a remote area with no telephone access. In England, Caroline's parents were becoming equally concerned as they too hadn't heard from their daughter. They assured themselves she was probably in the up back with no access to a phone or post office and would surely be in touch soon. The alarm bells really started to ring when Caroline's sister's birthday came and went on May 8th with no word from Caroline. A few weeks later, on May 24, when Caroline failed to contact her father to wish him a happy birthday, her family started to get incredibly anxious. A few days later, Caroline Clarke's family received a phone call from Joanne's dad, Ray Walters, advising them of his concerns regarding his daughter's silence.
两周后，乔安妮在威尔士的父母因为一直没有女儿的消息而感到不安。乔安妮是一个孝顺的孩子，经常打电话和写信回家，让父母随时了解她下一个可以联系的地址失联这非常不符合她的风格，但他们还是心存侥幸，希望她只是玩得太开心，或者目前正在没有电话信号的偏远地区旅行。在英国，卡罗琳的父母也变得越来越担心，因为他们同样没有女儿的音讯。他们安慰自己，她可能在内陆地区，没有电话或邮局，很快就会联系他们。当卡罗琳姐姐的生日在5月8日过去却没有卡罗琳的任何消息时，警铃真正开始敲响了。几周后的5月24日，当卡罗琳未能联系父亲祝他生日快乐时，她的家人开始变得非常焦虑。几天后，卡罗琳·克拉克的家人接到乔安妮父亲雷·沃尔特斯的电话，向他们表达了他对女儿失联的担忧。
Ray had recently been digging around and found that Joanne hadn't accessed her bank account since April 15, which was the day before she had last called home. He had also been in touch with Joanne's former employers in Australia, the Jensen family, who shared his concerns. They had expected to hear from Joanne over Easter, but the holiday had gone by without them hearing a word. Realising almost six weeks had passed since either family had heard from their daughters, they reported Joanne and Caroline's disappearance to local police, who then contacted the Australian federal police. The Jensen family also made their own report to New South Wales police in Sydney. Ray Walters stayed up late at night making international phone calls to fruit picking farms, backpacker hostels and rural police stations in areas Joanne and Caroline had already visited or intended to visit, but no one had seen or heard from them. Caroline's father, Ian Clark, was well connected due to his high level job at the Bank of England. He contacted an associate, Phillip Corbett, who was a former commander for Scotland Yard and was more than willing to assist the Clarks with the search for their daughter.
雷最近一直在查证，发现乔安妮自4月15日（即她最后一次打电话回家前一天）以来就没有动过银行账户。他还联系了乔安妮在澳大利亚的前雇主詹森一家，他们也和他有一样的担忧。他们本希望在复活节听到乔安妮的消息，但假期过去了却没有任何音讯。意识到距离两家人最后一次听到女儿的消息已经过去了近六 weeks，他们向当地警方报告了乔安妮和卡罗琳的失踪，警方随后联系了澳大利亚联邦警察。詹森一家也在悉尼向新南威尔士州警方报了案。雷·沃尔特斯深夜还在打国际长途电话，打给乔安妮和卡罗琳去过或打算去的水果采摘农场、背包客旅舍和农村警察局，但没有人见过或听说过她们。卡罗琳的父亲伊恩·克拉克由于在英格兰银行担任高级职位，人脉很广。他联系了一位同事菲利普·科贝特，他是苏格兰场的前指挥官，非常愿意协助克拉克一家寻找女儿。
Corbett made contact with Caroline and Joanne's former travelling companions to get a better insight into their movements. He also put pressure on New South Wales police to treat the disappearance as a priority. Corbett's intervention attracted media coverage in the United Kingdom, prompting Australian authorities to treat the missing person report with precedence. With New South Wales police now making inquiries, the disappearance of Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark was headlining the Australian media as a nationwide search commenced. A police spokesperson explained, Both women were in the habit of telephoning their parents about once every two weeks, but neither family has heard from their daughter since mid-April. Their failure to contact home is completely out of character, and it is for this reason we hold fears for their safety. Within the first day of launching the appeal, over 100 witnesses came forward to report possible sightings of the pair.
科贝特联系了卡罗琳和乔安妮以前的旅伴，以更好地了解她们的行踪。他还向新南威尔士州警方施压，要求将这起失踪案作为优先事项处理。科贝特的介入吸引了英国的媒体报道，促使澳大利亚当局优先处理失踪人口报告。随着新南威尔士州警方开始调查，乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克的失踪成为了澳大利亚媒体的头条新闻，全国范围内的搜寻工作随即展开。一位警方发言人解释说：“两名女性都有大约每两周给父母打一次电话的习惯，但自从4月中旬以来，两家人都没有听到女儿的消息。她们未能与家里联系是极不正常的，也正因如此，我们对她们的安全感到担忧。”在发出呼吁的第一天，就有100多名目击者前来报告可能看到这对双人组合的情况。
One witness reported seeing two women who matched Joanne and Caroline's description getting into a combivian with a male driver, which received strong media focus and generated hundreds of further tips. But police weren't convinced that it had been an accurate sighting. Further complicating efforts was the discovery that two young women with British accents were travelling a similar route to the one Joanne and Caroline planned to follow, meaning witness sightings could be confusing this separate set of travellers for the missing pair. Over the following two months, calls continued to come through and police followed up every lead, but none of the sightings were proven to be Joanne or Caroline. In August 1992, Joanne's parents Ray and Jill Walters travelled to Australia to assist the search for their missing daughter. They participated in press conferences, making an urgent appeal to the public for anyone with information to come forward.
一名目击者报告说看到两名外貌符合乔安妮和卡罗琳特征的女性上了一辆由男性司机驾驶的国民露营车，这受到了媒体的高度关注，并引发了数百条进一步的线索。但警方并不确信这是一个准确的目击情报。使调查进一步复杂化的是，人们发现有两名带有英国口音的年轻女性正沿着乔安妮和卡罗琳计划遵循的类似路线旅行，这意味着目击者的 sightings 可能会将这批不同的旅行者与失踪的两人混淆。在接下来的两个月里，电话源源不断地打进来，警方跟进了每一条线索，但没有一起目击事件被证明是乔安妮或卡罗琳。1992年8月，乔安妮的父母雷和吉尔·沃尔特斯前往澳大利亚协助搜寻他们失踪的女儿。他们参加了新闻发布会，向公众发出紧急呼吁，希望知情者提供线索。
Ray Walters told the gathering media, Joanne didn't do anything on the spur of the moment. If she turned right or she turned left, she'd let us know. On the day Joanne and Caroline were last seen in Sydney, only four months had passed since Gabor, Nugabella and Daniel Habschede had disappeared from the same area, and their case was still gaining media attention as their devastated families travelled the country searching for clues. Given that both pairs of international backpackers had vanished from the King's Cross District, the press were quick to link the two disappearances. New South Wales police refused to confirm whether there was a connection, simply advising they were considering all possibilities. Joanne and Caroline's case continued to gain an increasing amount of media attention, leading the press to look into other recent incidents where international tourists had gone missing under similar circumstances.
雷·沃尔特斯对聚集的媒体说：“乔安妮从来不做冲动的事。如果她向右转或向左转，她会让我们知道的。”在乔安妮和卡罗琳最后一次在悉尼被看到的那天，距离加博尔、努加贝拉和丹尼尔·哈布舍德从同一地区失踪仅仅过去了四个月，随着他们心碎的家人在全国各地寻找线索，他们的案件仍在获得媒体关注。鉴于这两对国际背包客都在国王十字区失踪，媒体很快将这两起失踪案联系起来。新南威尔士州警方拒绝证实是否存在某种联系，只是表示他们正在考虑所有可能性。乔安妮和卡罗琳的案件继续获得越来越多的媒体关注，促使媒体调查其他国际游客在类似情况下失踪的近期事件。
The mysterious disappearance of German backpacker Simone Schmidl two years earlier was mentioned from time to time, but very little was said about James Gibson and Deborah Everest, given they were Australian citizens travelling within their home country. Countless articles debating the safety risks involved with backpacking and hitchhiking were published, with the hostel industry coming under scrutiny. Hostel owners maintained Australia was a safe country and there was nothing for travellers to worry about, but the negative press was threatening to tarnish the thriving backpacker tourism industry. Despite this, young travellers were not deterred from hitchhiking. Many provided interviews to the media stating they had never encountered any issues while hitchhiking across the country, and had no intention of stopping, defending it as an affordable mode of transport.
德国背包客西蒙娜·施密德尔两年前神秘失踪的事件偶尔被提及，但关于詹姆斯·吉布森和黛博拉·埃弗里斯特的事情却很少被提及，因为他们是在国内旅行的澳大利亚公民。无数关于背包旅行和搭便车所涉安全风险的讨论文章发表，旅舍行业也受到了审查。旅舍业主坚持认为澳大利亚是一个安全的国家，旅行者无需担心，但负面新闻威胁到了蓬勃发展的背包客旅游业。尽管如此，年轻的旅行者并没有被搭便车吓退。许多人接受了媒体采访，称他们在全国搭便车时从未遇到过任何问题，并不打算停止，并为这是一种经济实惠的交通方式进行辩护。
Police called for the establishment of a central registry to record the names and contact addresses for all foreigners travelling in Australia to help keep track of their movements. Although that may have been a useful tool, it was too late for the families of the seven backpackers who mysteriously vanished in Sydney between 1989. and 1992. On September 19, 1992, eight members of the Scrub Runners Orientering Club ventured down the Hume Highway, passing the kilometres of pine plantations before reaching the natural bush portion of Balangelo State Forest. From the rangers' huts, the team separated into pairs and ventured into the thick scrub as part of a training exercise. Two members, Keith Sealy and Keith Caldwell, partnered up and began navigating the steep rocky terrain west of the Longacre Fire Trail, heading towards an area known as Executioner's Drop.
警方呼吁建立一个中央登记处，记录所有在澳大利亚旅行的外国人的姓名和联系地址，以帮助追踪他们的行踪。尽管这可能是一个有用的工具，但对于自1989年至1992年在悉尼神秘失踪的七名背包客的家人来说，已经太晚了。1992年9月19日，斯劳布奔跑者定向越野俱乐部的八名成员沿着休姆高速公路冒险，穿过数公里的松树林，到达了巴兰杰洛州立森林的天然灌木林部分。从护林员的小屋出发，团队分成小组，作为训练练习的一部分，冒险进入了厚厚的灌木丛。两名成员基思·西利和基思·考德威尔结伴，开始在朗埃克火路以西陡峭的岩石地形中导航，向一个被称为“行刑点”的区域前进。
At 4.15pm, the two men trekked into a shallow gully and made their way towards a large boulder. As they walked closer, they were hit with an overwhelming stench, which they assumed was emanating from a dead animal. They edged closer to the boulder, where they noticed a pile of sticks and branches on its western side, forming a mound approximately two metres long and 60 centimetres high. Out of the debris, they noticed a tuft of dark fur. They figured it must have been a dead wombat or a kangaroo. But upon closer inspection, they noticed a thin bone sticking out of the mound, along with a heel of a shoe and a patch of clothing.
下午4点15分，两名男子跋涉进入一条浅沟壑，朝一块大石头走去。随着他们走近，他们闻到了一股浓烈得令人窒息的恶臭，他们以为是从死动物身上散发出来的。他们向大石头靠得更近，注意到它西侧有一堆木棍和树枝，形成了一个大约两米长、60厘米高的小丘。在残骸中，他们注意到一撮黑色的毛皮。他们以为那一定是一只死袋娘或袋鼠。但在仔细检查后，他们注意到一根细骨头从土堆中伸出来，还有一只鞋子的后跟和一块衣物。
Keith Sealy, quote, What I thought was the kangaroo leg was an elbow. The wombat was the hair on the back of a head. The men hastily made the two kilometre trek back to the closest rangers hut, where they contacted police and escorted them to the human remains. A crime scene was established as twilight descended, with floodlights illuminating the deserted area as police uncovered the heavily decomposed body of a young woman, facedown and gagged with strips torn from a shirt.
基思·西利引述道：“我以为是袋鼠腿的东西其实是手肘。袋鼠其实是脑后勺的头发。”两男子匆忙跋涉两公里回到最近的护林员小屋，他们联系了警方并护送他们前往人体遗骸所在地。随着黄昏降临，犯罪现场被建立起来，泛光灯照亮了荒凉的区域，警方在那里发掘出一名年轻女性严重腐烂的尸体，面朝下，嘴里塞着用衬衫撕下的布条。
A search of the rugged terrain was put temporarily on hold due to the pitch darkness, with police commencing a thorough search of the site at daybreak. That next morning, just 30 metres from the skeletal remains discovered by the large boulder in the shallow gully, police noticed a similar mound of sticks and branches piled alongside a fallen log. Hidden underneath was a second body. When news of the gruesome discoveries in Belangelo State Forest hid the media, speculation ran rife as to whether more bodies would be uncovered at the site. In response, a police spokesperson said,
由于漆黑一片，对崎岖地形的搜查被暂时搁置，警方在天亮时对现场进行了彻底搜查。第二天早晨，距离浅沟壑大石头处发现的骸骨仅30米远，警方注意到一堆类似的木棍和树枝堆放在一根倒下的圆木旁。隐藏在下方的是第二具尸体。当巴兰杰洛州立森林恐怖发现的消息登上媒体时，关于该地点是否会发掘出更多尸体的猜测甚嚣尘上。作为回应，一名警方发言人说：
There is nothing to suggest that it's a mass grave, but we're keeping an open mind about what might be out there. To be continued next week. Thank you for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“没有任何迹象表明这是一个乱葬岗，但我们对可能存在的情况保持开放态度。”下周未完待续。感谢收看。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。